au milieu d'immeubles détruit il y a
même le sol Victor prépare le repas la
viande lui a été offerte par un soldat
ukrainien ce repas il va le partager
avec Alina 52 ans ici dans cette zone
résidentielle près de barghemouth les
habitants n'ont plus rien à Lina garde
tout de même espoir
nous ne sommes pas sans peur nous avons
aussi peur nous sommes des gens vivants
nous voulons aussi vivre
et je veux que tout cela se termine plus
vite ils doivent se mettre d'accord ou
ce problème doit être résolu d'une
manière ou d'une autre c'est tout
simplement insupportable
un peu plus loin c'est dans un sous-sol
sans eau sans électricité et sans
chauffage que ces civils ont trouvé
refuge à l'extérieur les Russes tendent
toujours d'encercler ce qu'il reste de
darkmouth la ville du Dombas s'est
entièrement détruite hier soir le
président
ukrainien a rendu hommage aux soldats
je remercie tous ceux dont la vie sauve
la vie de l'Ukraine
je tiens à rendre un hommage spécial à
la bravoure à la force et à la
résilience des soldats qui combattent
dans le dos basse c'est l'une des
batailles les plus difficiles
douloureuse et difficile
ont été repoussés dans plusieurs
secteurs du don-basse selon l'état-major
ukrainien